I was trying to figure out
who I was and how that could be fixed.
Something like that.
I started to pay very careful
attention to what I was saying.
I don't know if that happened
voluntarily or involuntarily,
but I could feel it sort of split
developing in my psyche and the split.
And I've actually had students tell me
the same thing has happened to them after
they've listened to some of the material
that that I've been describing to all
of you,
but split into two let's say.
And one part was the,
let's say the old me that was talking
a lot and that liked to argue and that
liked ideas.
And there was another part
that was watching that part,
like just with it's eyes
open and neutrally judging.
And the part that was neutrally judging
was watching the part that was talking
and going,
that isn't your idea.
You don't really believe that.
You don't really know
what you're talking about.
That isn't true.
And I thought,
hmm,
that's really interesting.
So now I've,
and that was happening to
like 95% of what I was saying.
And so then I didn't
really know what to do.
I thought,
okay,
this is strange,
so maybe I've,
I've fragmented and that's
just not a good thing at all.
I mean,
it wasn't like it was hearing
voices or anything like that.
I mean,
it wasn't like that.
It was,
it was,
well,
people have multiple parts.
So then I had this weird conundrum.
It's like,
well,
which of this two things are me?
Is it the part that's
listening and saying,
no,
that's rubbish.
That's a lie.
That's you're doing
that to impress people.
You're just trying to win the argument,
you know,
was that me or was the part that was
going about my normal verbal business?
Me and I didn't know,
but I decided I would go with the
critic and then what I tried to do,
what I learned to do,
I think was to stop saying
things that made me weak.
And now that,
I mean,
I'm still trying to do that because
I'm always feeling when I talk,
whether or not the words that I'm saying
are either making me align or making me
come apart.
And I think the alignment,
I really do think the alignment is,
I think alignment is the right
way of conceptualizing it.
Because I think if you say
things that are as true is,
you can say them.
Let's say.
Then they come up,
they come out of the depths inside of
you because we don't know where thoughts
come from.
We don't know how far down
into your substructure,
the thoughts emerge.
We don't know what processes
of physiological alignment
are necessary for you to
speak from the core of your being.
We don't understand any of that.
We don't even conceptualize that.
But I believe that you can feel that.
And I learned some of that
from reading Carl Rogers,
by the way,
who's a great clinician,
uh,
because he talked about mental health
in part as a coherence between the,
the,
the spiritual or the,
or the abstract and the physical
that the two things were aligned.
And there's a lot of idea of alignment
in psychoanalytic and clinical thinking.
But anyways,
I decided that I would start practicing,
not saying things that would make me weak.
And what happened was that I had to
stop saying almost everything that I was
saying.
I would say 95% of it as a
hell of a shock to wake up.
And I mean this was over a few months,
but it's a hell of a shark to wake up
and realize that you're mostly dead wood.
It's a shock,
you know?
And you might think,
well,
do you really want all
of that to burn off?
It's like,
well,
there's nothing left but
a little hosp 5% of you.
It's like,
well,
if that 5% is solid,
then maybe that's exactly
what you want to have happen.
Well,
so I told you that story is
an elaboration of this line,
and God saw that the wickedness of man
was great in the earth and that every
imagine have the imagination of the
thoughts of his heart was only evil
continually to question worth asking.
Just exactly what are your motives?
Well,
you know,
maybe they're purer than mine
were and it's certainly possible.
I don't think that I'm naturally
a particularly good person.
I think I have to work at it very,
very hard.
And I don't necessarily think
that everyone is like that,
but some people are worse than that and
everyone's like that to some degree.
So it's worth thinking about just how
much trouble are you trying to cause,
you know,
and the other thing you might think about
is that if you're not doing something
important with your life
by your own definition,
because that's the game
that we're playing.
You get to define the terms,
at least initially,
maybe you're prone to cause trouble just
because you don't have anything better
to do because at least it's trouble
is more interesting than boring.
You know,
that's something you learn.
If you read Dostoyevsky Dusty Husky
knew that extraordinarily well.
And so if you're not doing something,
if you're not pushing yourself
to the limit of your capacity,
then you have plenty of leftover.
Um,
what would you say will power,
energy and resources to devote
to causing interesting trouble?
And so,
well,
so I would say this is also
an archetypal scenario.
God saw that the wickedness of man
was great in the earth and that every
imagination of the thoughts of his
heart was only evil continually.
That's something to meditate on
and it's not self destructive
because what it is is an attempt to,
it's like the diagnosis of an illness.
It's like if that does happen
to be the case for you,
or to some degree,
maybe it's only 10% of you or something,
or maybe it's 90% well then coming to
terms with that is excellent because then
maybe you can stop doing it.
And what would be the downside to that?
You'd have to give up your resentment,
obviously in your hatred and all of that.
And that's really annoying
because those emotions are very,
they're easy to engage in in there and
they're engaging and they have this
feeling of self righteousness with
them and that goes along with them.
But
you're not doing this in
order to put yourself down.
You're doing this in order to separate
the wheat from the chaff and to leave
everything that you
don't have to be behind.